J'étais un soldat solitaire dans la
jungle folle et cette jungle est le monde
[Musique]
Je pensais toujours à la raison pour laquelle les femmes de
mon pays ont peur de montrer
qui elles sont sexy ou que les gens jugent
les gens sur ce que nous sommes tu sais  et
si tu regardes un beau vêtement ça veut dire que
tu es une bonne personne si tu es très légèrement il y en
aura six ton open close ça
veut dire que tu es une mauvaise personne j'ai travaillé
comme mannequin pendant longtemps et je
me souviens que les gouvernements commencent  pour attraper
des mannequins en 2015 certaines personnes vont en
prison certaines personnes ne peuvent pas sortir du pays
pendant longtemps et c'était fou après
c'est peut-être 80% des photographes et
des mannequins qui commencent à arrêter de travailler
[Musique]
J'ai eu des nouvelles de  mes amis qui
se sont rendus à Istanbul à cette époque et ils ont
dit que votre nom était sur la liste et que le
gouvernement avait tellement soif de
vous tuer et de vous botter le cul, vous savez qu'il
disait exactement cela à ce moment-là
après quelques mois, je comprends que je
peux  retourner dans mon pays
Dieu seul sait à quel point j'ai pleuré peut-être toute
la nuit je marchais dans la rue j'avais
un peu d'espoir de pouvoir y retourner je peux
retourner chez mes amis ma famille ma maison
mon chat tout sauf en une nuit  J'ai
compris que je suis seul
[Musique]
quarante-huit chez moi la nuit où j'étais
Je dormais en mettant mon dos ici et
je devais mettre mon dos sous mes fesses
et m'asseoir dessus jusqu'au matin
Je dormais comme ça
[Rires  ]
première nuit je n'ai même pas dormi de toute la
nuit je pleurais je disais dieu
quelle était mon erreur les gens ne me font pas confiance les
gens me font peur vous savez vous pouvez
croire quand je dis aux gens que je suis
réfugié  ils pensent que je veux trouver un
moyen ou deux de les utiliser ou de faire quelque chose Je
ne sais pas ce qui est arrivé à ces gens
mais allez je suis humain
tu sais et si je suis réfugié ça ne veut pas
dire que j'ai tué quelqu'un ou  quelque chose comme
ça Je viens d'un Je fuis
des lois stupides qui sont en place
[Musique]
Je veux continuer mon travail Je veux me
battre pour mes droits
Je veux me voir comme une
femme qui réussit Rien ne peut me faire peur J'ai dormi
dans  la rue je m'enfuis de mon pays
j'ai passé des moments vraiment fous les gens voulaient
me violer tout m'est arrivé même
je suis mort en ce moment je ne perdrai rien il
n'y a pas moyen que je dise je veux
arrêter je continuerai ou je mourrai
[Musique]
vous